the european council and parliament have  sealed an agreement on the eu's budget  for next year  the two sides agree that payments in  2014 should be set at just over 135  billion euros and that commitments be  limited to under 143 billion euros the  deal marks a significant decrease in  spending compared to last year  we reinforced the priority  areas such as growth  employment and innovation  we also agreed to reinforce financing on  migration  border protection and humanitarian aid  the agreement came after the latest in a  series of conciliation committees aimed  at bringing together the positions of  the council on parliament  the deal included more than 400 million  euros to help four eu countries recently  hit by natural disasters  this is the first annual budget in the  eu's new long-term spending blueprint  the multi-annual financial framework or  mff that runs for the next seven years  it's expected to be formally adopted by  the end of november